senior foreign affairs correspondent and
Face the Nation moderator Margaret
Brennan joins us from Washington
Margaret good morning good morning to is
did ambassador sunland's testimony was
it enough to move the needle for the
Democrats well for the Democrats
ambassador Sunland who is a lifelong
Republican donor was a powerful witness
here he did say point-blank there was a
quid pro quo and he brought it to the
president's office he said he was
executing it in coordination with the
president's personal attorney at the
direction of the President himself
that's significant however for
Republicans they will certainly point to
that wiggle room Sandlin provided when
he said he was never explicitly directly
instructed by the President to execute
this scheme of trading Ukrainian
military aid in a meeting at a White
House for politically convenient and
useful investigations for the president
so it is something that Republicans will
certainly point to there Margaret
ambassador Sunland testified that vice
president Pence and Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo were quote in the loop on
all of this what's the significance of
that well vice president Mike Pence
would become the president of the United
States in the very unlikely scenario at
this point that the
republican-controlled Senate were to
actually follow up on the impeachment by
voting to remove the president from
office so to have this scandal widened
implicate the vice president who has
really tried to keep his hand cleans
hands clean and all of this is
significant for Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo also someone in line at the very
top of the cabinet this further
embroiled him in a scandal that has
really enveloped and damaged the State
Department that he runs it lends further
credence to the argument made by
Democrats that national security was
being sublimated or perhaps sacrificed
for the president's own political
benefit and it could be damaging to any
future political career he wants to have
Margaret we know that David Holmes and
dr. Fiona Hill are expected to testify
today they are key witnesses what should
be we what should we be looking out for
in terms of what they have to say and
connecting all the dots well as Nancy
Cordes pointed out Fiona Hill is a
Russia expert actually one of the top in
the
World inches a former intelligence
analyst she's going to lay out why this
was so risky to play politics with this
particular part of American foreign
policy Ukraine why it is so beneficial
to Vladimir Putin she'll lay out the
damaged portion of this and why she
thought these newbies to diplomacy like
Master Gordon sunland were dangerous she
actually called him a
counterintelligence risk and clueless
David Holmes perhaps most significantly
for the Democrats will be able to take
this from the president's door inside
the Oval Office by saying he had
first-hand knowledge by overhearing a
conversation between the president in
the United States and ambassador Sunland
he says on July 26 that they sat outside
at a restaurant and that Gordon sunland
turned to him and said the president
cares more about dirt on the Biden's
than he does
Ukraine likely to be another dramatic
day on the hill Margaret thank you